[Music]
in not the dog news submitted by cat
person
oh I like cats but not the people that
own cats
you're literally sandwiched between cat
evil what are you gonna say hey got you
oh yeah you know I can't people do you
know what I love dogs more than cats
but I wouldn't [ __ ] on cat people I said
I love cats you heard that you don't
like the cat people I'm in the vote oh I
hate cats
but I want to be one that's an
interesting camp I think I'm a cat too
actually
what the [ __ ] what not even close to a
cat I thought was a loner no you're a
dog as [ __ ] no he's a he's a lizard he's
a dog he's a lizard I'm a dog yeah dogs
are social I'm social have you met
meatloaf have you met Tyson they're not
social at all there are traumatized
animals this guy hello it's true a city
took a family's dog and sold it after
they could not pay their bills like the
telephone bill or some maybe they're
alone how to do that hey you couldn't
pay for it you've got so poor you had to
sell his dog at an after Rock you know
that he paint like 100,000 for his dog
tell me very famously yeah why did I say
Jersey all right sounds like CDs in
Philly I'm like put the fight rocky
helped him get his dog back that same
big old dog that Mastiff that's the same
way I had to get rid of Oh No and he
could have made rocky earlier but they
didn't want him to star in it and he was
like nah wait so he was that poor and he
[ __ ] waited so he deserves it all
yeah he does that dudes I'm led you know
cuz yes cerebral palsy right or no bail
Bell's palsy yes Bell's palsy which gave
him a lazy eye and in that flirts he's
only five six or something he's short
they're like cuz he just [ __ ] worked
hard but he wrote it you wrote it to
star in it I have to be my shade that's
a really good filmmaker yeah he's
incredible barely anyone the operative
that year yep
so he's just to nobody it was like the
Ben Affleck and Matt Damon of that
generation yeah where he just came out
of [ __ ] nowhere and won an Oscar and
everyone's like who the [ __ ] is this guy
that's cool I already like Stallone now
I really like oh yeah he's man he's
[ __ ] do follow my Instagram no I
don't you should he does all kinds of
like his shows like how he started so he
look like in his office where he writes
all the time he just has stacks and
stacks of old scripts like Alfred
Hitchcock scripts like all his favorite
like writers and stuff and then he just
went like open them you know show you
what he highlighted and he's like taking
notes and understanding what made a good
screenplay so he can adapt it to
Expendables yeah so he understands his
branding so obviously he makes things in
the scope of his branding he knows his
audience but he is also really looking
at the classics and seeing what makes
them tick and so he's a student of the
art form which I really like about him
have you seen [ __ ] Copland
complet and he's so [ __ ] good and
competition watch it he's legit
shouldn't want an Oscar for it
in college yeah when I saw that he's the
man and complan dude go watch coplann go
walk stop watching this video and go
watch [ __ ] good
don't even watch this video it's over
anyway prom I promise you we're out of
scene watch complan thank you Taikan if
they eat it's dope dude no I'll check it
out
yeah it's dope wasn't that like straight
to [ __ ] VHA oh dude it was into pizza
no it's I think who did is a diploma or
somebody no it's a [ __ ] good is it
before like yeah yeah
also it's all I know I think it might be
after cliffhanger yeah so lon might gain
weight for the role if he's got like a
potbelly for it oh wow he's like a cop
in a small town that is completely built
and run by cops but it's literally rocky
though he's the sheriff we got man no
it's not Bobby he acts like rocky no
very humble and rocky yeah same person
yeah he is but no but no no no wait have
you seen Coppola enough yeah cuz it's
really [ __ ] good right yeah so much
[ __ ] tough talking it in ray liotta
how do you remember you watch these
things as an adult again yeah I watch
all the [ __ ] I watched a movie day so I
watch three rush at all times none yet I
have to go home and watch one remember
when he puts on the VR goggles and he
and it's likes xxxxX
I thought sex was like that probably
watch complan first no a dread dread
with 2d oh we were trying not to talk
about I know so don't go by the dog town
in Germany seized a family's dog over
unpaid TechEd taxes and so they said it
looks like what the [ __ ] did I have to
do with this get rid of one of those
kids yes so this dog was deemed the most
valuable possession that the family has
remember to be more taking the dog Bank
is harsh bro before taking the dog they
were trying to take the the the dad
wheelchair but they found out that the
wheelchair they're just gone for low
blows isn't the family's priest it so
they couldn't take it because the
wheelchair belonged to some other agency
or whatever the dog is this like some
purebred like special dog that's like
it's a $9,000 dog that's why 400 on
they've an Instagram dog with a Jif mom
I used to sell wheelchairs do not that
much money so whatever this is it's
gonna be a disappointing amount and our
German Shepherds still called German
Shepherds in Germany is it a power
wheelchair - a great question I don't
know what tempo wheelchair but I do know
that the dog was listed on eBay from a
private eBay account which is sure
enough we've been on it um no so someone
bought it it was for about it was 750
euros about eight hundred and forty
dollars yeah that's useful but the
person who bought the dog said that she
liked this dog was crazy cheap because
she was like what the hell I expected to
pay it and double the price for the this
time I got a discount
anyway she ended up getting the dog and
then she found out that this dog had a
lot of health issues the dog needed for
eye surgeries or for operations due to
eye problems the French Bulldog
including an ox and emergency and yeah
they're calling it a pug oh this dog
needed an emergency operation over
Christmas - soap she got a lemon yeah
she ended up paying a total of a
thousand eight hundred euros for all of
these operations and so she demanded the
town to pay back for the operation and
then also the [ __ ] is going on right now
the amount that she spent living town
this is good yeah the town that sold her
the dog cuz it's a German town who sees
this dog and sold it on eBay make sense
to me is this like a German clog village
it sounds like some village bickering
why don't I picture
like females and like they're doing big
dudes in like your suspenders and
[ __ ] got mini accordion yeah it's
[ __ ] baking over at look potatoes and
bratwurst yes and I'm just making
headlines like what the [ __ ] this town
like this is so shady child they're
saying that the spokesman for the city
said that no enforcement officer would
come up with the idea of taking the the
wheelchair because they're like aides to
guarantee the mobility of people with
that's funny cuz they tried taking it
yeah exactly wasn't worth enough no it
wasn't the family didn't own it so we
couldn't take it from the family but
then the aren't the same we would never
do that
yeah what kind of fucked-up town is this
pretty [ __ ] up town you get my dogs on
eBay exactly what the [ __ ] is your name
of this town it's called Copland the
times call call call plan germany it's
spelled it's a sh wits ok aah
Elian i want to go to germany wait so
did town so the towns just like hey guys
everyone needs to know that these people
always money and that's why we took
hints we seized his dog and sold it and
everyone's show with that it was a
pedigree by the way but no not everyone
came with papers I mean they're calling
in a pic yeah I think it's one of those
special that's always like oh it's
probably really valuable like it's those
special dogs where did he go money for
him this family owed money and unpaid
taxes including the dogs text which most
of Europe has gotten rid of but Germany
doesn't want you rid of it because it
brings in I should cent of money every
year a dog yeah damn I wonder how much
taxes they pay because you know I heard
I mean Germany is like the country
that's keeping the rest of Europe going
with their economy other countries nots
there like there are they're a pretty
big economy I think the one that people
like the parents take off like six
months or something crazy when they have
a kid or a whole year or something
that's why the lazy French no I heard it
was Germany is it true it might be I
don't know maybe Canada - it's one of
the lazy country yeah I'm thinking
Switzerland
the Year Netherlands ah but even the
dietary lazy yeah both parents they take
off for like a whole year or something
work when is you think allow that it's
all day never we weren't being
[Music]
[Applause]